I was speaking with Jonathan paggio this
morning because he's staying in the same
same era B&B as my wife and I and he
suggested that I talk to you about my
experiences with media over the last
year and I thought well that's a that's
something I know about so it's always
good when you're talking to people to
talk to some talk about something that
you know about that's actually a really
good tip for public speaking right if
well it's really true you have to
remember that you should know about
three times as much about the topic as
as you need to talk about the topic and
then you have places you can go and you
know you can wander around a little bit
and be a little spontaneous so that's
really useful and but then I also
thought that makes sense because nobody
knows anything about the situation with
regards to the media now and so we're
all feeling our way and so because the
technological transformations are so
rapid and you know they're going to come
one after the other in the next 10 years
I don't think we can even imagine what's
coming down the pipes and we're all
struggling to keep up and you know we
don't even know how much of the current
state of more radical political
polarization is actually a secondary
consequence of technological
transformations that we don't understand
because I was thinking today about you
know about Facebook and about Twitter
and about YouTube and about the idea
that people are in an echo chamber and
I'm not really sure that's the right
metaphor I think we might be in an
amplifier rather than an echo chamber
you know and I've thought for a long
time that when I'm when I'm thinking
about the effect of the individual I
read something that Solzhenitsyn said at
one point and I think he was citing a an
ancient Christian theologian who defined
the universe as a place that's whose
circumference was nowhere and whose
center was everywhere and I really like
that idea it's I think it's actually
relatively true from a technical
perspective like from a physical
perspective but some motion it's
imported out that each of us was to be
regarded as the center of the cosmos and
and that we have the power that's
associated with that and I've thought
about that a lot because there's
something about it that's oh that's it's
either obviously true or it's true
enough so that we all acted out when we
interact with each other because we
treat each other like conscious beings
who have
destiny and who have choices and who
make choices that are important and who
make choices that can be good or bad or
even good and evil we all act like that
so we act that out and I was thinking
that you can think of network models in
that way you know you can think of human
beings as like nine billion dots in a
row and there's no connections between
the dots and then you sort of like a
dust mote in the wind and who the hell
cares what you think anyways and you
don't have any impact on things or you
can recognize that you're at the center
of a networked system and that you know
you know a thousand people or you will
in your lifetime or perhaps more than a
thousand people and then they know a
thousand people so you're separated by
one person from a million and two people
from a billion and that's a much better
way to think and we are seriously
networked together and we're networked
together more now than we ever have been
and so one of the things that that might
mean is that the choices you make are
amplified and distributed not only far
faster than they ever have been but with
far more impact